please welcome back to the show friend
of the show and
one of my dearest friends pilar valdez
hello
all right hi drew hi pilar thanks for
having me happy new year well when i
didn't see you this morning i was like i
hope pilar's okay
i'm like right because we're doing this
today very much
uh okay and excited to be here laura and
i literally spend
almost every day together and we love
food and we love
laughter and we love you know
traveling the globe we're very
into every flavor the study you're
self-taught yeah
totally i'm self-made yes there you go
and i always see us wearing those
t-shirts together
because it proves you don't have to have
a degree you don't have to have had a
certain economic
or cookie cut cookie cutter journey you
can
find yourself wherever you are in the
world you're in manila i was here
here we are together and food has
brought us together it certainly has
friendship all right tell everybody what
we're making so i'm really excited
actually to share today's recipe with
everybody because it's one of i think
our favorite recipes that we make
together
i think it's so original it's um perfect
for all seasons but it's especially
satisfying during the winter months
so it's a roasted uh poblano and
tomatillo soup
so good it's got the creaminess there's
there's spice there's heat there's pops
of acid
it's really beautiful so shall we get
cooking let's do it all right so the
first thing we did was actually roast
off the poblanos the tomatillos the
shallots and the jalapenos
all together one piece all together in
one sheet pan what time
425 degrees 25 to 30 minutes until
they're like
golden and they start to release their
juices release the juice
the juices um and this step you can
actually do up to five days ahead
so you can park it in your fridge and it
can hang out for five days for five days
in the fridge it also makes a really
mean salsa mmm
salsa i mean if you're like me i just
love to drink salsa so the soup is an
excuse to drink my salsa i drank it last
night before bed
so what we have going in this spot
actually is
two cups of leeks that we're sauteing in
some avocado oil
salt and pepper until they're wilted and
translucent and beautiful
i also love avocado oil because there's
an amazing list called like the hateful
eight or the you know it's about oils a
woman put it out
what oils are more optimal for cooking
with and avocado is on point
it's really really beautiful so what
we're going to do is take your sheet pan
with all those beautiful roasted
aromatics and peppers
and you're going to toss it in make sure
to scrape up all those juices
that it released because that's where
the flavor
of this recipe is i have to say and you
know
pilar and i are the biggest cookbook
junkies we've built our collection
together we speak in cookbook and
visuals
and instagram posts and references and
tagged and sharing
and um i'm really loving the sheet pan
cooking
it just doesn't intimidate me it's it's
really really accessible to everyone so
to that pot drew we're gonna add
our beans and we're using thin-skinned
cannellini beans over here
thin skin thin skin whitening skin
cannellini
and that really adds to the creaminess
of the dish
and then drew this is one of the other
secret ingredients here you're going to
pour
in the aquafaba which is really just
bean
cooking water unfortunately named it
sounds so much better aquafaba
and it's this magic ingredient you can
actually use it
as like an egg white mayonnaise you can
make mayonnaise
you can do all sorts of things with it
but in this recipe because it's vegan
we add it in to add that like really
luxurious mouth feel a rounder feeling
to the whole soup i feel like
about aqua faba that it's like a vegan
dietetic
roux possible possible like it's
just a thickening it's totally a
thickening agent you're absolutely right
and then we're going to pour in uh the
water which is two and a half cups of
water
okay and next beautiful we're gonna
bring this up to
a boil and then we're gonna simmer for
like voila
five to ten minutes just so those
flavors really melt
simmer five to ten minutes simmer five
to ten minutes let everything
come together and then the next step is
actually
we blend it until it's creamy no
blenders today
we had a blender incident we did so we
blended
and you're going to add some fresh
cilantro on it fresh cilantro into
it we blended it with it actually in the
soup it's already in the soup it's
really beautiful
and what we're going to do now i know
you hate to hurt an herb i hate you're
very genuinely with her
to hurt her take a knife to her
occasionally occasionally um so actually
this soup is really great because it
freezes up really well
and i think it's really crowd pleasing
for um this recipe is served
six and it comes out to just over four
dollars per serving
so you can eat it as is just like this
or you can garnish it with a little we
have a little coconut yogurt over here
um some toasted pepitos for crunch
i love toast and a little
coriander as well and some sliced
jalapeno
the last thing i forgot to mention about
this dish is that we actually also added
after we blended whole beans and you let
that simmer for a little bit
because you want the creaminess up
against those little pops of texture
which is really really lovely i'm going
in
this is one of my favorite soups of
yours it was such a revelation the first
time i had it i'd never tasted anything
like it
that's why i was excited to share it on
the show with everybody
because there are certain certain soups
where i'm like i've seen eighty thousand
iterations of this
this is a true original just like you
pilar oh
thank you i love you all right go to our
website
and make this soup tonight why not
i love you love you thank you